american voters feeling some serious
buyer's remorse with president biden
things not looking up for the
commander-in-chief exactly one year out
from the midterms as americans deal with
soaring inflation and empty store
shelves nearly 60 percent say they
disapprove of joe biden's job
performance only 38 percent approve and
roughly half of independents think the
president has done a worse job than they
even expected adding to the president's
headache the rising price of gas biden
is considering shutting down another oil
pipeline despite runaway prices and his
energy secretary claims there's not much
the white house can do to ease pain at
the pump
could the average gas price in america
be four dollars a gallon in the united
states soon well we certainly hope not
the president is all over this of course
every president is frustrated because
they can't control the price of gasoline
because it's a global market the
president blaming the press while
suggesting most people don't understand
the supply crisis
what i'm going to try to do is explain
to the american people as best i can
and by the way you all write for a
living
i haven't seen any one of you explain
supply chain very well
no no i'm not being critical
i'm being deadly earnest when your
editor says explain the supply chain
okay
lots of luck in your senior year as my
coach used to say
jesse whenever the politicians start
talking about a communications problem
instead of the fact problem i get a
little suspicious yeah biden shouldn't
be mocking americans for not
understanding current events dana that's
my job
but this is the reason we have this
supply chain crisis and if you don't
know now you do biden and his buddies a
couple years back put all the american
factories in china in asia and now we
have a problem with the shipping if they
stayed here in the western hemisphere we
wouldn't have this type of problem
and he doesn't understand supply and
demand they're just trying to kill this
line five pipeline in canada say you
kill it tomorrow right we don't go green
tomorrow you're still going to have to
truck and train all the gas to the
united states that's going to raise
costs and it's going to increase
emissions and this poll is a catastrophe
for democrats he's at 38 approval on the
economy he's in the low 30s
in covet he's underwater in immigration
dana he's in the teens
he's in the 20s in
i think foreign policy and then most of
democrats a lot of them big chunk and a
lot of independence don't even want him
to run
and they think he's an incompetent
failure and then so you turn your
attention to number two kamala harris
she's in the 20s dana it is the worst
number of a sitting vice president in
modern american history it's bad so
that's why a lot of democratic donors
are now looking to bypass kamala shift
the money to mayor pete so he gets the
nomination in 2024. that sets up a huge
cage match between kamala
mayor pete bernie for the heart and soul
of the democratic party and as you like
to say i'm here for it i'm here
imagine dana if he didn't have a corrupt
press propping this guy up he'd be at 28
percent look at the last week he goes
and falls asleep overseas and then he
passes wind
so blatantly that the house of windsor
is still talking about it
and then he comes back and he raids the
home of a conservative conservative
journalist over his daughter's missing
diary and then we find out it turns out
not only the democratic party fund the
dossier the democrats put the lies in
the dossier and he plans on paying
certain illegals millions of dollars
imagine if they covered
this president like they covered the
last president this would have been
reverberating everywhere i always like
to talk to you on mondays
because you get like it's got a lot of
pent up energy and then a long weekend i
loved it i loved it um what about that
uh
poll numbers poll numbers are bad oh you
mean you don't want to you don't want to
focus on that you're gonna move past
that you're gonna pass it yep you're
going to pass the gas yep
i was just amazed that they were
impressed by the length of it
rather than the sound but anyway it
should be easy for joe to work from home
right because it is the white house
that's his home all you got to do is
roll out of bed and take the stair lift
and you're there but he's it's like he
doesn't know any what's going on whether
it is the 450 000 payout or it's supply
chain it's like he's kept in the dark
like a rare organic mushroom and and
then then he's kind of like wheeled out
like a daughtering old consultant for a
few hours and then he floats around
checks his watch until it's his nap but
that's what that's factored into the
presidency they know what they're
getting and they're allowing other
people to run the show it's just that we
don't know who it is you know we it's
not like
we we have an absentee father but our
absentee father is replaced by the
manson family dana
it's hyperbole monday
but it is true
uh uh
um biden it's naturally to see a decline
in polls because every every president
has a honeymoon and there's only so much
you can say about the person's dog right
right but trump never had a honeymoon or
a dog no that's true and i love that you
had the opposite of a honeymoon which is
what you call marriage no
no you had a good weekend i said yes i
see i see um harold i have a theory um
but when asked what sort of the
infrastructure bill the president did
get a legislative win it happened on
friday night and i think that one of the
things is if you look at that bill they
had the votes for all of that in april
but they decided to wait and so what
happened since then you had the supply
chain crisis inflation you have
afghanistan um amongst other things that
are going on immigration and so the
infrastructure bill passes and it's sort
of like not even a blip but could it
help the president sort of regain some
footing
you're the only one here that's been in
the white house and worked closely with
with the president i think it can
christmas
visited trump on a number of occasions
this is true
it got a lot of swag he did if we were
if we are sitting here if i'm invited
back to sit in february march and he is
with these numbers we have a real
problem you got primaries already taking
place in the country uh so i think
there's a way for this to turn around
there's no doubt they should have done
this back in may june july july august
september when they had the could have
potentially influenced the outcome of
some of these elections
the other thing is democrats got to have
got to take the
push the reset button themselves and
realize voters vote in federal elections
but they live local lives crime public
education jobs cost of living you have
to confront and meet people where they
are in their lives there's nothing wrong
with talking about the national issues
two democrats and republicans trump is
no longer the factor in the midterms if
you want to win younkin has given given
republicans a path of giving republicans
a playbook and democrats who think all
you need to do is raise donald trump's
name and you're going to fire people
it's not the case you saw an
african-american woman and an hispanic
man also elected in the commonwealth of
virginia lieutenant governor and the
attorney general
racializing everything so quickly not
the right thing you got to meet people
where they are going to talk about the
things that matter to them and that they
care about and a funny thing happens
black people white people brown people
other couples we all want the same thing
we don't want to pay more for bread
jesse doesn't want to pay more for gas
greg doesn't want to pay more for
anything and not any of my
african-american or white friends want
that meet people where they are have an
agenda and bring people together if you
do that you can turn it around if you
don't if we continue playing this kind
of politics
we're going to find ourselves listening
to results and perhaps the worst thing
is that immigration thing
the president
needs to explain this now there has to
be a standard if you go and apply for a
government service right and you follow
the rules and the government manages the
outcome of it and all of a sudden they
lose your child during the process there
has to be a standard of care there and
there probably is a remedy for that i'm
certain it's not 450 000 but they've got
to figure out how to explain this and
then
that story sat out there for three or
four days before they ever even asked
about it and
and then then they're like insulting
americans for
being
concerned about the issue i think that
they need to be doing a lot less
explaining like their professors talking
to people who are paying way too much
tuition in a college course the strategy
from the white house so far with every
single crisis has been to ignore it to
act like it's not happening to tell
everybody it's not happening americans
aren't stranded in afghanistan there's
nothing we can do about oil and gas
prices where people know that they can
do something about oil and gas prices
because we've done it before we were
producing our own oil we became
independently uh
strategic and also dependent on
ourselves for energy in this country not
reliant on opec now the bind
administration is going back and begging
opec to pump more oil so that we can
have cheaper prices when we can solve
that problem tomorrow by approving
drilling leases by not trying to shut
down more pipelines and the other thing
is
you know they're acting like
they don't care and maybe they don't
maybe they know that joe biden himself
has said he might not run in 2024 they
know that the vice president has been a
total disaster she got her trial run
it's been a complete failure and maybe
their strategy is they know they're
gonna lose 2022 so they're going to push
through as much as they can now and then
try to clean it up later with someone
else but that seems to be the issue and
then for th for biden lastly to say the
press needs to explain the supply chain
better okay people can go to the grocery
store they can go to their local store
they can see there's a problem they can
see the photos of all the shipping
containers office off the ports they
don't need to be explained to or to read
in the newspaper what's going on when
they can feel it every single day with
their paycheck hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else